the deadline to send your holiday gifts
so they arrive in time for Christmas is
quickly approaching and here are three
deadlines for those of you who are
slackers first-class mail and Priority
Mail need to be sent by Thursday UPS and
FedEx have a Friday deadline and the
Postal Service says packages sent with
Priority Mail express need to be mailed
by Saturday shipping companies expect a
record year fueled by e-commerce buying
something online kicks off a nationwide
sprint to get your package on its way
and Kris Van Cleave is in a cargo plane
at Washington Dulles Airport
International Airport to see how it all
happens Chris good morning well good
morning this md-11 makes for a pretty
big sleigh and when it leaves Washington
later today it will be loaded with
Christmas presents UPS expects to
deliver around 800 million packages this
holiday season that's a lot Wednesday
could set a record for the company 37
million deliveries that's more than 425
a second and nearly double a normal day
from the unending roar of jet engines to
the constant hum of conveyor belts it's
beginning to sound a lot like Christmas
at UPS Worldport in Louisville Kentucky
do you feel a bit like Santa's helper
yes I do we have a little thing here at
UPS
and it's just like Santa except we
deliver all year-round
UPS's main package sorting facility is
working around the clock processing 115
packages a second
why are you busier this year than you
were last year really its ecommerce it's
been a sync change when was the last
time you went to a department store
you're online now you're clicking and
and purchasing and as soon as that
purchase is made a shipping label is
created a UPS shipping label and then
that package is on its way
boxes arrive at Worldport by plane in
these containers they're sorted by folks
like Gary Hallett one of 11,000
employees here every year about this
time gets me excited because I know
we're delivering somebody's go what's on
the conveyor belt the packages wind
their way through the 5.2 million square
foot facility these codes on the boxes
are repeatedly scanned directing them to
Jordan Maynard's area the belt knows to
drop a box in just the right bag headed
to just the right place so the system
reads this code and knows
we're in here it's supposed to go and
what bag to drop it it that's right
there thousands of bags in this room and
then what got this specific bag that's
gonna go through the packages aren't
here very long when they come in the
door line their way through a hundred
and fifty five miles of conveyor belt
get sorted and sent on their way we're
talking less than twenty minutes
by then the bags of packages are loaded
into these freight containers Lesley
Goren calls boxes it's like a game of
Tetris just finding the right spot we
caught up with her as she was pushing
2,000 pounds of packages onto a flight
to LA she's not superhuman the ground
has wheels making loading easier and
faster and while she's packing planes
meteorologist Jeffrey server is scanning
the skies for bad weather our biggest
job is to look at any weather it's going
to impact our operation and try to find
a way around it mitigated is it the
delay of flight speed of flight up or
just change the network then it's up to
the pilots who fly ups is 248 planes
plus 35 more they've leased for the
holidays it's not a stretch to say
you're kind of flying Santa's sleigh I
would agree with that I would agree with
that my kids certainly agree with that
captain Sean Hortons tie even says I am
Santa he knows he's not but he's happy
to help old Saint Nick understand the
weightiness that responsibility and we
do our best to make sure that no kid is
disappointed on Christmas morning
once Hortons 767 lands the packages make
their way to those brown vans UPS calls
them packaged cars and to your door by
Christmas if you make one teeny deadline
the last day is Friday the 21st shipped
something next air and it'll be
delivered on Christmas Eve don't wait
ship now I know it looks empty right now
but that won't last in fact when this
plane leaves Washington pretty much
every inch in here will be full up to
200,000 plus pounds of gifts this plane
is going to Worldport in Louisville it
won't be there long as soon as it's
unloaded it'll load back up and start
making deliveries again Nora I love
seeing that Chris thank you so much and
a big shout out to all the UPS employees
they work so hard and what a process I
always love kind of peeling back the
layers to see how people do their job
complained when something doesn't go
right and we never say thank you every
day when everything goes right right
hundreds of thousands of pounds of stuff
that goes right and gets there amazing
great story Chris thank you so much